now here's the question if Cain and Abel
were the only two children of Adam at
the time after Cain kills Abel who is he
afraid of because he says now anyone who
finds me will kill me right and so how
there's nobody else re read Genesis 4
everyone if you read Genesis 4 nor does
it say Cain and Abel were the only
children let me now correct that
misreading listen now because this is a
common objection if you read it mentions
Eve giving birth to Cain and Abel but
then it says a period of time elapsed a
course of time elaps so that means many
years went by how do we know because now
Cain and Abel are grown one is tending
flocks the other is tending the ground
do you expect me to believe they came
out of this mother mother's womb one is
a farmer the other is a
Shepherd or did it take a some time
but but
Sam I thought this once but I I saw that
that test when he was
born H his mother Eve was 120 years old
maybe she was can you show me what it
says she was
12 uh why you making up stuff like as
long the way you know on your way
1 when Adam had lived 130 years he had
his son on likeness in his own image him
Seth you misquoted it again what did I
say you said Cain who how old was Adam
and Eve when they had Cain and
Abel I don't know so then why are you
going to Genesis 5 about Seth because
that's not talking about Seth as the
third child it's saying later on after
Abel was killed Seth was appointed to
replace Abel doesn't mean there weren't
other children among all the children
Seth was chosen not the other
just like when David had many sons
Solomon is chosen not the others so when
Abra oh I'm sorry Jacob had 12 sons
Joseph where are you getting there was
only
Seth h no no no I'm not getting that I
am saying even if he had more children
they would be not more than 120 years
old so if if Eve had that child every
year she would had like
120 children so let's say Kane is 40
years old how old would the rest
be not older than 40 okay so that means
they're still in in their teens and 20
so they can kill Kane
right that is correct so what's your
argument you're making no
sense that is true because I think of it
like like okay but but but the people
know that this is Kan why does God need
to put a sign on him because what do you
think listen to yourself listen to
yourself who do you think would want to
kill Kan for murdering
able everyone no why everyone they don't
know who able is who gives a dam who
would want to kill Cain for killing Abel
his other brother ah now it makes
sense you get it now yeah yeah yeah
that's why he's afraid that's why he's
afraid they're going to hear about me
killing our brother now they're going to
come after me to kill me for what I did
and God says no that is true no that's
not going to happen they're not going to
touch you because I'm going to punish
them so if you read the story in context
and not misread it like you just did oh
if he's 40 they're not old 40 or you
mean a 15-year-old can't take a knife
and stab
you he can okay so who cares they're not
40 they're still in their teens and in
their 20s hello George hello George hold
on Timmy wants to come in should I let
Timmy
speak it's okay let let me now run you
through
it in Genesis 4 it's talking about Cain
and Abel because it's going to talk
about Cain killing Abel so they're the
main
characters
right she want to talk about the first
murder but they didn't come out of their
mother's womb hey Kane I'm going to go
and tend the flock and you and become
you know the Gardener you know T it says
a course of time meaning a period of
time elapsed they were mature and old
enough so that one could tend the flocks
the other tend the ground
right right so where does it say in that
period of time they didn't have other
Sons and
Daughters it doesn't say because the
story is not about how many kids Adam
and Eve had after can and Abel how old
were they and trying to make a specific
point so it's focusing on the main
actors Kane and Abel because Cain kills
Abel it's trying to mention the first
murder that's the focus of that it's
like you see a movie right in a movie
I'm the main actor you may find the
scene in which I go home and have my
family there but they're not the focus
of the film I
am right that's correct okay so Genesis
4 the focus is on Cain and Abel and Cain
murdering a it's not interested in
telling you how many other Sons and
Daughters were born but that there were
other born two factors number one it
says this took place after a period of
time years went by so unless you assume
Adam and Eve lived like months and had
no children why would you assume
that I can't assume something I don't
know so here let's use your logic uh Eve
we had Kan and Abel let's take a break
from having and having children what do
what do you think
that's true you get right I mean now
when think about it common sense right
so what was Kane and Abel doing I'm
sorry Adam and Eve doing they were
playing what they were playing
poker no they were they were reproducing
to make the Earth full okay thank you so
there were many sons and daughters at
that time but they're not mentioned
because they're not part of the story
the story is how Caine murdered his
brother how evil he was
right so now it makes sense the second
fact that we know there are other what
is Kan worried about if he goes to a
foreign land who's going to know they
didn't have internet they didn't have
newspapers right that's true so that's
true if he went away no one will know
right okay I murder someone let's say in
Iraq there is no internet no newspapers
and I flee to Jordan why am I going to
be afraid who in Jordan knows what I did
no one
so then why is Kane afraid that whoever
Finds Me will kill
me because his brothers will find
exactly his other brothers and sisters
can say what happened to
Abel oh he's killed who killed him came
after
him that is correct so where's the
problem there's no problem if you think
about it in a yeah in a common sensus
you got to man unless you want to think
that Adam and Eve were playing patty
cake you know what Eve enough kids let's
play patty cake patty cake patty cake
bakers that is true because this
argument they use it a lot the the the
atheist and this stuff but they say they
want to prove some errors in the Bible
so they Pro it as an error like there it
proves that they're stupid that they
should be reading comic books because
they're not educated enough to read
serious books right that's just correct
because if Adam and Eve are man to have
children are you telling me after Kan
and Abel G said you know what I need a
break Adam I can't handle
this just see so anyway hope that's
clear so any other questions